okay it's your boy psycho bucket babble
okay we are back and we are Joe is
chapter five our lives I believe a spy's
otherwise known as Weber brush stick
much Mitch candles to stuff an oven okay
I'll just drinking my coffee you know
how it is that busy not hot as I said we
got a jump right and yeah I love you but
that's chef Vita hosen now you guys are
some silly people huh it's just thing we
thought of the work it's like okay the
only trucks I had to jump in the water
and swim with you one I didn't know what
[ __ ] tie to take out the Couture
giant do is turning like no one [ __ ]
told me that I mean I'm not complaining
I'm just you know like covering up
friends a lot too much just put the clip
in front of the hospital okay I get it
now
oh yeah I'll warm you up you put a meter
that birding sure that's all right
anyway this is your new what's my now
shut the [ __ ] over there
the [ __ ] is this hike a talking car
through here right right yeah how about
my hair bye bye help my baby
Oh mr. Meck Meck whatever is talking
ahead this is close
he's a mouse ate used to be enough it
was on the board how's it possible we're
in the very center of Berlin you're
hiding in a place night let's go to what
head unless you have plans over there
the most common yeah ah that's good yeah
a blast kovitch I should have known only
you would be dumb enough to do a daytime
enter the lady led to his new best
friends Terron your lives
Fox Carol sitting in a bag living three
pulverized vertebrae you head trauma 4
inches of cast iron shrapnel right in
the [ __ ] still in their separate :
septic shock shattered pelvis memory
loss flashbacks 14 years in loony bin
good to happen is our best batch how did
you smell so what about my Cola what can
you do
ah bang me she's my girl pleased to see
you too turquoise just supposed to be
big but I get sleep you've been gone for
three months but anomaly people don't
come back so eyes involved you either
don't seem to the books I've heard
stories about you I was told you died in
1946 information always do you wanna
know who you are
we searched Anya mum of this I think I
talked about we have to revise my whole
model thank you very much thank adhering
interesting things out of London I have
a folder marked project whisper but
someone has borrowed it Klaus I believe
it was a colossal mind it won't bring it
to me - please captain now that you are
here
becomes really great see why don't you
sit with me
miss Anya listening on these friction
anything out of London take notice the
time and write down as much as you can
here is pen or paper can I get a grater
and on the background how to type yes
yes my parents thought I should learn
for you to take dictation prescriptions
on such bonds are not really it was
useful during my time at the University
of London for my doctorate in
archaeology then the bits came and I had
to go back home I was only 16 well
doctor please assist me in figuring out
what these damn Nazis Oh fine project
West Park all right you got it baby
yeah I got it I shut the wall take ten
days to go through all that that would
eat other Bobby Brown I hope you looking
for the project with the folder it's not
here obviously a check like I don't
attach that door now what is this your
lights which kind of sucks okay where's
the project folder things are kind of
glimmering a little bit I can walk
around okay
because nothing on big big fun make on
the [ __ ] Celeron up here you know about
before going off on you like that forced
to have it
noise Johnny cowboy it's not the first
time it happened here perhaps you should
consider moving in tattoos I will in
time I wasn't you Americans say all wet
when I got them and I'm sorry to say it
was a very proud moment of my life
I want removing them to be an even
prouder moment no one that sees know
what that so long as you don't get in
the way me killing Nazis will see eye to
eye
Caroline's looking for a document folder
project whisper max doesn't speak
English very well but he does know
project whisper risky business operation
he knows it'll cost us to put it out max
doesn't like violence he doesn't want to
see anyone get back out the flat Allison
oh the mic on the then finish came from
Caroline said you borrowed the folder do
you have it here did take it two days
ago but they put it back go to the
ground floor the folder should be in the
drawer in a desk in her room it was I
left beat his head so [ __ ] flat look
at is room his max what was acting what
sign in there some project Lister folder
your name chroma or find a way around I
could occur by I guess I think seems
like glimmering do you see that
I think it's cuz of the focus this room
looks empty maybe we could sleep in here
could use some shot that's late man air
the [ __ ] going on that's it Oh going
to help upgrade was that always there to
back to sleep at dead cop up at big papa
in deep
ok ok wash [ __ ] in this lot of [ __ ] in
this up crowbar I can ah ok let's go
back to sit this room
hello sir
max I really need your step side max
beat a gate so exciti da steady screech
ding max come here come on
I sold them [ __ ] out with this guy
sorry I should have known you would have
taken it take I just got lucky I was
just looking that drawer what's over
there
America surrenders [ __ ] is way too
much [ __ ] on their last goods are we in
Fergus Ferguson burgers right well this
Hawk was gone market I was in a real by
the month [ __ ] off what a menace I can
slit right wake me if I say huh
the skies about to fall or some sort of
shite oh [ __ ] okay anyways we're down
here some [ __ ] going on up here
exit level I think I've so much ID to
get some plastic ovitch ready for an
assignment yes friends and comrades this
is it project whisper it's been in
development for years
a helicopter aircraft the Nazis have
found a way to make it virtually silent
in flight when undetectable by means of
red onion has decrypted the Nazi chatter
out of London and located the only three
prototypes in existence at the London is
not to go research facilities there
let's go from Stettin finally set
rolling up to strike at separation
today's a scurrying like rats are over
these machines in our possession we can
go anywhere kick anything people can
feel the price outer arm are
self-sufficient we will rise up and take
them this head to put facing supports
over suppose we don't have that cuts to
a pulse I've got a sinus infection I've
never enjoyed sleeping in a month so
let's go people
because I'm not doing this again you've
got balls of steel Bobby but I'll stop I
just want to get yourself away [ __ ]
okay uh I'm pretty sure that's the
[ __ ] meter sorry we're going to see
what level one
yeah okay we're Chapter six okay I'll
wet it here
thank you